officially 8 30 this morning 8 30
eastern time
it was announced that we had our second
consecutive negative quarter of gdp in
the u.s economy that has been the
technical definition of a recession for
probably
100 years probably a century or so
that's what everyone has always said
we've got evidence of that we'll show
you in just a second
but
not our people in charge right now
here's black lesbian korean jean-pierre
she is the white house press secretary
uh and she's telling peter ducey that
the thing that we've always known is not
really the thing if things are going so
great though then why is it the white
house officials are trying to redefine
recession no we're not redefining
recession if we all understand a
recession to be two consecutive quarters
of negative gdp growth in a row and then
you have white house officials come up
here to say no no that's not what a
recession is it's something else how is
that not redefining recession because
that's not the definition that is not
the definition
said in 2008 of course economists have a
technical definition
which is of a recession which is two
consecutive quarters
of negative growth
i can tell you this they said two
consecutive two negative quarters of gdp
growth is not the technical definition
of recession it is not it is not why did
he say that it is not i can i can speak
to i can speak to you to what he said
yesterday in front of all of you which
is the last thing that you just repeated
there are many factors there are many
factors economic factors and indicators
to consider
and
i will say that the textbook definition
of recession is not is not two negative
quarters of gdp
okay so you know she just lies like
they're so in the lies it's all they can
do uh she never actually we watch the
full clip she never actually explains
then if it's not the common definition
of two consecutive quarters of the gdp
shrinking that uh if that's not the
definition of recession what it is but
what's interesting that peter ducey who
is just fantastic i mean he really out
of all the people in the white house
press corps he's just doing a great job
for fox and he's really the only one
asking these direct questions uh he
brings up this guy brian diese
who is joe biden's national economic the
head of the national economic council
he's the director here's the exact quote
i this is what ducey read but i just
thought it was worth showing you guys
again this is the guy that's in charge
of the national economic council right
now for joe biden well what did he say
back in march of 2008 economists have a
technical definition of recession which
is two consecutive quarters of negative
growth
this is the guy who's in charge of the
thing for the elderly man pretending to
be president right now
he's also a black rock guy but let's
just that's a little sidebar thing
but the point is that they are going to
try to change the definition of words
right now these are the same people who
try to change the definition of
everything right boys or girls two plus
two is five uh you know just being
non-racist is actually being racist and
the rest of those things and you can now
watch what's fascinating this is what
we're going to get to in a second is now
watching the entire machine just do it
right in front of us and this is what
they do all the time they do the magic
trick right in front of us even though
we know how they're doing the magic
trick and yet a certain amount of people
still get bamboozled by it